I'd like you to imagine the world anew
I'd like to show you some maps which
have been drawn by Ben Hennig of the
planet in a way that most of you will
never have seen the planet depicted
before here's an image that you're very
familiar with I'm old enough that I was
actually born before we saw this image
apparently some of my first words were
Munna Munna but I think that's my mum
having a particular fantasy about what
her baby boy could see on the flickering
black-and-white TV screen it's only been
a few centuries since we've actually
most of us thought of our planets
aspherical when we first saw these
images in the 1960s the world was
changing at an incredible rate in my own
little discipline of human geography a
cartographer called Waldo Tobler was
drawing new maps of the planet and these
maps have now spread and I'm going to
show you one of them now this map is a
map of the world but it's a map which
looks to you a little bit strange it's a
map in which we've stretched places so
that those areas which contain many
people are drawn larger and those areas
like the Sahara and the Himalayas in
which there are a few people have been
shrunk away everybody on the planet is
given an equal amount of space the
cities are shown shining bright the
lines are showing you submarine cables
and trade routes and there's one
particular line that goes from the
Chinese port of Dalian through past
Singapore through the Suez Canal through
the Mediterranean around to Rotterdam
and it's showing you the route of what
was the world's largest ship just a year
ago a ship which was taking so many
containers of goods that when they were
unloaded if the laws had all gone in
convoy they would have been a hundred
kilometers long this is how our world is
now connected this is the quantity of
stuff we are now moving around the world
just on one ship on one voyage in five
weeks we've lived in cities for a very
long time but most of us didn't live in
cities
this is chattel hullick one of the
world's first cities at its peak 9,000
years ago people had to walk over the
roofs of other's houses to get to their
home if you look carefully at the map of
the city you'll see it has no streets
because streets are something we
invented the world changes it changes by
trial and error we work out slowly and
gradually how to live in better ways and
the world has changed incredibly quickly
most recently it's only within the last
six seven or eight generations that we
have actually realized that we are a
species it's only within the last few
decades that a map like this could be
drawn again the underlying map is the
map of world population but over it
you're seeing arrows showing how we
spread out of africa with dates showing
you where we think we arrived a
particular times I have to redraw this
map every few months because somebody
makes the discovery that a particular
date was wrong we're learning about
ourselves at an incredible speed and
we're changing a
lots of change is gradual its accretion
we don't notice the change because we
only have short lives 7080
if you're lucky 90 years this graph is
showing you the annual rate of
population growth in the world it was
very low until around about 1850 and
then the rate of population growth began
to rise so that around the time I was
born when we first saw those images from
the moon of our planet our global
population was growing at 2% a year if
it had carried on growing at 2% a year
for just another couple of centuries the
entire planet would be covered with a
seething mass of human bodies or
touching each other and people were
scared they were scared of population
growth from what they called a
Population Bomb in 1968 but then if you
look at the end of the graph the growth
began to slow for decade the 70s the 80s
and 90s and noughties and in this decade
even faster our population growth is
slowing our planet is stabilizing we're
heading towards 9 10 or 11 billion
people by the end of the century within
that change you can see tumult you can
see the second world war you can see the
pandemic in 1918 from influenza you can
see the great Chinese famine these are
the offense we tend to concentrate on we
tend to concentrate on the terrible
events and the news we don't tend to
concentrate on the gradual change and
the good news stories we worry about
people we worry about how many people
there are we worry about how you can get
away from people but this is the map of
the world changed again to make area
large the further away people are from
each area so if you want to know where
to go to get away from everybody is
the best places to go and every year
these areas get bigger because every
year we are coming off the land globally
we are moving into the cities we are
packing in more densely there were
wolves again in Europe and the wolves
are moving west across the continent our
world is changing you have worries this
is a map showing where the water falls
on our planet we now know that and you
can look a where travel hullick was
where three continents meet Africa Asia
and Europe and you can see there are a
large number of people living there in
areas with very little water and you can
see areas in which there is a great deal
of rainfall as well and we can get a bit
more sophisticated instead of making the
map be shaped by people we can shape the
map by water and then we can change it
every month to show the amount of water
falling on every small part of the globe
and you see the monsoons moving around
the planet and the planet almost appears
to have a heartbeat and all of this only
became possible within my lifetime to
see this is where we are living we have
enough water this is a map of where we
grow our food in the world this is the
areas that we will rely on most for Vyse
and maize and corn people worry that
there won't be enough food but we know
if we just ate less meat and fed less of
the crops to animals there is enough
food for everybody as long as we think
of ourselves as one group of people and
we also know about what we do so
terribly badly nowadays you will have
seen this map of the world before this
is the
map produced by taking satellite images
if you remember those satellites around
the planets and the very first slide I
showed and producing an image of what
the earth looks like at night when you
normally see that map on a normal map
the kind of map that most of you will be
used to you think you are seeing a map
of where people live where the lights
are shining up is where people live but
here on this image of the world remember
we've stretched the map again everywhere
has the same density of people on this
map if an area doesn't have people we
shrunk it away to make it disappear so
we're showing everybody with equal
prominence now the lights no longer show
you where people are because people have
everywhere now the lights on the map the
lights in London lights in Cairo
delights in Tokyo D lights on the
eastern seaboard of the United States
the lights show you where people live
who are so profligate with energy that
they can afford to spend money
powering lights to shine up into the sky
so that satellites can draw an image
like this and the areas of the dark on
the map and either areas where people do
not have access to that much energy or
areas where people do but they have
learnt to stop shining the light up into
the sky and if I could show you this map
animated over time you would see that
Tokyo has actually become darker because
ever since the tsunami in Japan Japan
has had to rely on a quarter less
electricity because it turned the
nuclear power stations off and the world
didn't end
you just shown less light up into the
sky there are a huge number of good news
stories in the world
infant mortality is falling and has been
falling at an incredible rate a few
years ago the number of babies dying in
their first year of life in the world
fell by 5 percent in just one year more
children are going to school and
learning to read and write and getting
connected to the Internet and going on
to go to university than ever before at
an incredible rate and the highest
number of young people going to
university in the world are women not
men I can give you good news story after
good news story about what is getting
better in the planet but we tend to
concentrate on the bad news that is
immediate Rebecca Solnit
I think put it brilliantly when she
explained the accretion of incremental
in perceptual changes which can
constitute progress and which render are
either dramatically different from the
past
the past was much more stable contrast
and have obscured by the undramatic
nature of gradual transformation
punctuated by occasional tumult
occasionally terrible things happen you
are shown those terrible things on the
news every night of the week you are not
told about the population slowing down
we were not told about the world
becoming more connected you are not told
about the incredible improvements in
understanding you are not told about how
we are learning to begin to waste less
than consume less this is my last map on
this map we have taken the Seas and the
oceans out now you are just looking at
about seven point four billion people
with the map drawn in proportion to
those people you're looking at over a
billion in China and you can see the
largest city in the world in China but
you do not know its name
you can see that India is in the center
of this world you can see that Europe is
on the edge and we in Exeter today on
the far edge of the planet we are on a
tiny scrap of Rock of Europe which
contains less percent than 1% of the
world's adults and less than half a
percent of the world's children we are
living in a stabilizing world an
urbanizing world an aging world a
connecting world there are many many
things to be frightened about but there
is no need for us to fear each other as
much as we do and we need to see that we
are now living in a new world thank you
very much